So there's still one more feature that you could
add to your project to round out functionality for
registering for a conference. Once you've registered, you can't
actually unregister. So even though the UI shows us the
Unregister button, users can't actually click it to unregister,
because you haven't written the functionality to unregister the
user from a conference. It's up to you if
you'd like to go ahead and implement the unregister functionality.
Feel free to add the function unregisterFromConference and
put it in conference API if you'd like. I'm
going to leave you to do this on your
own if you want to. Couple things, though, I
do need to point out, is that the
UI is expecting the function to be called unregisterFromConference
and it is expecting it to throw these exceptions.
One other thing here is we have an @Name("websafeConferenceKey"),
so this function knows to expect the web safe conference
key to be passed to the function, and if you go
to the API's explorer, you'll see that it offers the
websafeConferenceKey field for you to enter the value if you want.
Anyway, it's up to you if you'd like to go
ahead and implement this function. But it does tie together a
lot of the concepts that you've learned such as using
transactions and getting an entity by key and changing property values.